[Musique]
à la préfecture du rhône
hier après-midi un certain nombre de
responsables régionaux ont étudié la
possibilité de relier lyon saint-etienne
et grenoble à la vitesse de 300 km heure
il ne s'agit pas de science fiction mais
d'un nouveau mode de transport
l'aérotrain mis au point par une équipe
française que dirige monsieur jean
bertin l'inventeur et ses collaborateurs
ont présenté une maquette aux personnes
présentes parmi lesquelles messieurs
ricard préfet de région greffe préfet de
la loire doublet préfet de l'isère et le
maire de lyon monsieur pradel ainsi que
celui de grenoble
monsieur du but de cette nouvelle
réalisation qui intéresse déjà très
vivement les américains verra peut-être
le jour dans notre région entre lyon et
grenoble ou bien lyon et saint-etienne
monsieur jean bertin nous présente
maintenant les principales
caractéristiques de l'aérotrain il n'ya
pas d'organe qui sont en contact avec la
voix la voiture est supporté par des
coussins d'air ici est guidé également
par des coussins d'air ces coussins
d'air sont créés par des ventilateurs
actionnées par des moteurs et des
puissances est limité et une fois que
cette guidage 7 sustentation était ont
été obtenues la machine peut aller à
peupler la vitesse qu'on veut c'est
certainement un des moyens les moins
chères d'obtenir une grande vitesse mais
vous c'est sale je crois ce qu'il faut
retenir
qu'attendez vous pour grande vitesse
pour l'aérotrain et bien entre 200 et
400 kilomètres à l'heure c'est à dire
des vitesses qui n'ont qui ont déjà été
obtenus bien sûr avec des véhicules à
roues mais en exploit isolé et non pas
en trafic de tous les jours donc c'est
pour une solution pour les moyennes
distances
essentiellement nous pensons que c'est
une solution pour délais
et distant des dix ans ils ont comprises
entre 50 et 200 300 km voilà c'est
l'ordre de grandeur qui nous paraît
favorable
nous allons maintenant demander aux
principaux responsables de notre région
si ce premier contact avec l'aérotrain
les a convaincus sur l'intérêt de ce
moyen de transport révolutionnaire tout
d'abord monsieur reid car préfet de
région préfet du rhône
vous avez parlé de procédé
révolutionnaire par définition les
préfets ne sont pas très favorables aux
révolutions puisqu'ils sont garants de
l'ordre
mais en l'espèce je vais déroger aux
principes habituels
je suis absolument convaincu de
l'extrême intérêt que présente un tel
procédé
déjà il ya quelques mois à l'occasion
d'une réunion parisienne
j'avais pu me pencher sur le projet de
monsieur bertin et la réunion
d'aujourd'hui m'a convaincu bien plus
encore de l'extrême nécessité d'avoir
grâce à ce procédé
des relations extrêmement fréquentes
rapide entre les trois grandes villes et
qui font la capitale tricéphale de notre
région
lyon grenoble et saint-etienne
je souhaite que très bientôt nous
puissions nous réjouir à la pensée que
ce procédé va connaître une très rapide
une très heureuse réalisation monsieur
grève préfet de la loire vous savez que
les pouvoirs publics ont décidé de faire
de lyon une grande métropole régionale
ce sera une métropole bipolaire lyon
saint-etienne il est dans cette optique
absolument indispensable qui est des
légions abondante et rapide entre
saint-etienne et lyon
je crois que en dehors de la liaison
autoroutière qui a son intérêt
spécifique
la formule de l'aérotrain est capable de
résoudre un certain nombre de problèmes
liaison entre les deux villes
à vitesse rapide monsieur du boomer de
grenoble l'intérêt est en train il est
évident dewilde rapportant ce lyon
grenoble séparé par un relief aussi
difficile d'améliorer les communications
au point permis par les autres un risque
de changer totalement la nature des
relations entre ces deux villes
[Musique]